Buenas tardes es la primera consecuencia
de la décima jornada de protestas que
tuvo lugar ayer y de la que informamos
en a France veinticuatro bueno la
ministra los invita dice para conversar
muchos temas están abiertos todos los
temas posibles los sindicatos ya han
dicho que van a hablar de los 64 años
quieren reducirlos a 62 años sobre la
necesidad de poner en pausa esta reforma
de la jubilación están polémica y de
buscar una mediador pero el ministro de
relaciones con el parlamento francés ha
dicho que el tema de los 64 años no
estará en la agenda de esa reunión que
ha sido fijada para el tres cuatro o
cinco de abril el líder de la cfdt que
es el sindicato más conservador que es
el que usualmente termina negociando con
el gobierno en caso de crisis sociales
ha dicho que el tema de los 64 tiene que
estar Sí o sí o si no él se levantará y
se irá todavía la cgt no responde sí
asistirá a este encuentro con la primera
ministra Elizabeth Lo cierto es que que
ella había anunciado Ya esta semana que
quería reunirse no solo con los
sindicatos sino que también con
políticos diputados parlamentarios para
ir haciendo consensos con respecto a los
proyectos que van a venir en el futuro y
evitar crisis sociales como la que
estamos viviendo actualmente